à commencer par vous loue vous avez 21
ans vous êtes équipiers en restauration
à strasbourg et vous dit ceci j'ai une
trans identité non binaire à savoir que
je me ressens je me ressens des deux
sexes mais surtout je me considère
femmes alors que mon sexe a signé à la
naissance cet homme mais ça c'est la
situation présente à partir de quel âge
ou à partir de quel évènement vous avez
senti que pour vous
la distinction entre femmes et hommes ne
fonctionnait pas
c'est compliqué à définir parce que sa
demande de remonter plus loin que ce que
je suis capable de faire déjà et en plus
de ça c'est compliqué à définir parce
que ce n'était pas un rôle précis dans
le temps
en fait c'est plus un problème qui est
lié au fait qu'on n'est pas du tout
renseigner sur la transidentité dans
notre société actuelle
du coup on ne se rend pas compte des
signes qui peuvent qui peuvent nous
mettre la puce à l'oreille est
typiquement j'ai cru pendant très très
longtemps que j'étais un garçon avant de
me rendre compte que ça ne correspondait
pas de me renseigner beaucoup sur le
sujet d'apprendre énormément de termes
qui sont pas simples à appréhender à la
balle on va généralement on va on
aborder quelques uns préciser les
définitions au fur et à mesure des
années je me suis rendu compte que la
définition garçon ne convenait pas donc
c'était il ya quelques années que je me
suis rendu compte que ça ne m'allait pas
du tout et donc j'ai commencé à me
renseigner sur la non binarité et la
transidentité et donc ça doit être aux
alentours de il ya deux trois ans que
j'ai vraiment commencé à me poser des
questions et au fur et à mesure de
fréquenter des personnes trans de
m'enseigner sur le sujet d'attractif
dans la communauté lgbt qui je me suis
rendu compte que ben j'étais beaucoup
plus à l'aise avec les accords féminin
beaucoup plus à l'aise avec les
expressions de gens fument ils ont barré
abordé juste après et à vous avez vous
avez utilisé quelques termes qui pour
vous son tour où son family mais bien
sûr c'est par exemple non binarité
est-ce qu'on peut définir le plus
simplement possible ce qu'on entend par
non binarité alors déjà faut savoir que
non binarité troisième genre c'est des
termes qui sont
comment dire qui coexistent le troisième
jour c'est un terme très très simplifié
pour parler de mon binarité dans le sens
où c'est pas un terme qui est exact
parce que ça implique qu'un à 15 alors
qu'il ya plein de type 2 non binarité
différentes et j'aurais même tendance à
dire qu'il ya autant de types de nos
minorités qu'il existe deux personnes
aux mineurs chaque personne un rapport à
son identité de genre qui est différent
même parmi les personnes si ce genre
donc les personnes qui se reconnaissent
dans leur genre assigne à la naissance
et donc chaque personne va appréhender
au fur et à mesure de sa vie ce qui lui
correspond la non-vie narith et ça
implique juste ne pas se reconnaître
dans les étiquettes sommes à 100% ou
femme un sens pour ça donc par exemple
être un peu à mon un peu femme ou être
aucun des deux ou être les deux à la
fois où des fois lors des x l'autre et
il ya plein de plein de mots comme ça
qu'ils existent mais dans l'ensemble des
fonctions plus simple c'est ne pas se
reconnaître 100 % à 100 % foot alors ya
un sujet qu'on va évidemment abordé dans
le détail mais je voudrais juste
l'effleuré avec vous dans votre vie
quotidienne
cette indétermination comment c'est reçu
par votre entourage vous avez l'air très
à l'aise pour ans pour en parler en
public est ce que dans la vie
quotidienne ça se passe toujours aussi
bien non c'est pas la fin que j'en sais
pas la première fois que j'ai ce
discours là et c'est pour ça que j'ai
l'air à l'aise c'est que je le fais
peut-être trois fois par semaine toute
les nouvelles personnes que je rencontre
avec qui je me sens suffisamment à
l'aise à toutes les personnes de ma
famille qui ont pas été au courant
pendant un temps de mon entourage de mon
travail j'ai la chance d'avoir un
entourage qui est très compréhensif mais
le fait est que c'est un discours qu'on
a beaucoup parce que souvent les
personnes ne sont pas renseignés en
s'adressant à nous élus que nous on est
parce qu on est passé à travers tout ça
va éduquer au fur et à mesure les
personnes et vu qu'on fait très souvent
on a tendance à connaître les bons
termes
de manière générale dans ma vie de tous
les jours je me définis avec des accords
au féminin parce que c'est plus simple
mais mais après on est effectivement
chaque véhicule est différent chaque
personne ne se définit d'une manière
différente en fonction de ce qu'elle
ressent de mon côté c'est vraiment plus
je suis une femme transgenre non binaire
mes proches le savent mais que l'aigle
savent ma famille le sait la plupart des
gens le prennent bien alors j'ai demandé
au chroniqueur de se prononcer pour ou
contre la reconnaissance d'un troisième
genre nous avons une invitée qui elle
est contre ces virginité l'aisne
déléguée générale et fondatrice
d'ailleurs de l'avenir pour tous ces
auteurs de l'humain plus fort que le
marché c'est un livre qui est paru en
novembre 2015 alors vous venez
d'entendre à plaidoyer très tranquille
et pourtant vous vous êtes contre la
reconnaissance d'un troisième genre
quels sont vos arguments
virginie alors merci déjà de m'avoir
invité et merci à nos amis de nous
expliquer ce qu'il en est parce que
c'est pas simple pour les gens de
comprendre non m'envoyer les
pédagogiquement mais étape par étape
déjà on a compris non binarité parce que
vous avez été très clair we insist en
fait ce que j'entends c'est que c'est
une disparition des sexes d'ailleurs le
terme genre remplace le terme sexe et
c'est en cela que nous nous opposons à
l'avenir pour tous à 7 ce changement de
la structure humaine de l'être humain
sexuelle sans pour autant et là je vais
peut-être un peu vous décevoir parce que
le conflit ne sera pas aussi fort sans
pour autant exclure de notre société et
de sa reconnaissance sociale des
personnes qui aujourd'hui ont une
autonomie parce que nous sommes au 21ème
siècle les technologies ont évolué que
nous savons nous pouvons changer de sexe
par exemple je le vis très de façon très
proche en ce moment dans ma famille par
des gens qui sont sur très proche dessus
de nous mais pour autant comme je le
défends des déjà il y a huit ans je nous
pensons qu'il ne faut pas dans la vision
de l'avenir de l'humanité il ne faut pas
effacer les sexes
attendez moi c'est parce que j'ai
entendu j'ai entendu qu'on rajoute et
voit l'un traire une catégorie on
n'efface pas les deux autres hommes
femmes
or donc s'agit pas d'effacer hommes et
femmes et de rajouter une catégorie si
nous prenons toutes les précautions pour
ne pas effacer les deux sexes surtout en
termes non pas de l'individualité des
personnes qui s'auto détermine
absolument aujourd'hui elles le peuvent
mais et c'est là où j'en viens toujours
à la génération qui va venir et qu'il ne
doit pas être modifié
on ne va pas être modifiées
génétiquement parce que c'est quand même
de cela aujourd'hui qu'il est question à
partir de ce moment là si la structure
ray
cet homme femme mâles femelles comme nos
gammes est le sont effectivement je
pense que pour les commander tout ce qui
est de l'état civil personnel je ne vois
pas pourquoi il n'y a pas une mention
d'un autre type
mais pas le changement de la structure
humaine d'accord donc vous êtes pour la
reconnaissance alors sur la gamme état
civil personnel le gros problème c'est
l'acte de naissance à mais quelle
distinction vous faites entre les deux
est ce que l'enfant ne peut pas on ne
peut pas d'ailleurs c'est à vous que je
pose la question
effacer la sexuation de l'origine des
enfants c'est à dire que s qui viennent
d'un homme d'une femme et ce qu'ils se
reconnaissent avec leur gamme est
assignée à l'eau moi la femme
il est là on est dans la transmission
alors je vais pour les structures
humaines